Jim Miran is the chairman CEO of MGM
Resorts he's a big deal I think that's
what it says on his business card Jim
kind enough to join us Jim good morning
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me all right explain the deal with the
NBA and MGM for the lay person then that
means me so here in the US it's been
illegal to gamble on sports outside of
Nevada until the Supreme Court just as
passed may overturned that law so now
over the next several years almost every
state in the US will allow its residents
to gamble on sports in knowing that MGM
wanted to be a leader in sports betting
and reached out and worked with the NBA
to become their official sports betting
partner and what that means is that MGM
will get all the real-time data all the
information so that sports betters can
make informed investment decisions and I
think then this is gonna be the first of
many moves that MGM makes in the sports
world what do you mean well there'll be
other league relationships there'll be
other opportunities to work with
partners overseas for example it's a
pretty young industry here in the US at
least the legal part illegally was over
150 billion dollars gambled here in the
US illegally mom as it becomes legal you
know we reach out to our neighbors
across the sea in Europe obviously it's
extremely popular and so I partnered
with GVC this is a company that owns
Ladbrokes and corals and you know
they're my partner here in the US and
what it means locally for you all you
know I'm from Fairfield by the way dan
so we're opening a casino up in
Springfield Mass a [ __ ] Massachusetts
folks will be able to gamble in sports
next year new jersey we own Borgata
that's happening right away and this is
gonna roll out throughout the US all
right what's this mean for the fan and
make the convenience of betting
well what it means I think what it's
meant overseas and I think it'll mean
here is better fan engagement you know
if your team's up or down by a ton you
know it's tough to watch but if you've
got an economic interest in the game in
the fourth quarter for example you're
going to be more engaged in the
experience itself it's more exciting
it's more social so you know my buddies
on my softball team and Connecticut you
know we're going to compete against each
other to see who's doing better late in
the game so it improves I think social
interaction and improves fan engagement
therefore improves viewership of games
which accrues to the value of the teams
and the league's which is why the
leagues and the teams are so interested
to work with us the key to this stand
though is integrity you know if people
don't believe that they're getting
crystal-clear accurate trusted
information they're just not going to
feel comfortable betting and so that was
the the principle message and issue we
dealt with with the NBA with Adam silver
yesterday integrity trust of the
information to preserve the value of the
games when do you think we're going to
be able to bet on our phones it depends
on what state you live in you can do
that right now in Las Vegas where I am
or right now you'll be able to do it New
Jersey in a few days you'll be able to
do it I think in Massachusetts within
two years
Connecticut's a little bit tortured
because of the duopoly you have with the
Pequots and Mohegan Sun the the
Connecticut legislature is not quite
clear how it wants to approach sports
betting but every state will be a bit
different but I would I would surmise
that within the next ten years you know
over half the states in the United
States will not only allow you to bet at
a sports book that in one of our resorts
but more importantly online and that's
really what people want to do
if I'm driving through Delaware but I'm
not from Delaware then you'll be able to
when you're in Delaware you'll be able
to bet because it's geo-located to the
state oh okay right yeah that's what I
was curious about what's uh where do you
stand with the NFL in partnering with
them we're actually you might be we're
we're the the company that helped lead
the Oakland Raiders for those in Oakland
you I'm sorry but we're the ones that
led the Oakland Raiders here to Las
Vegas that stadium opens in 2020 they'll
be playing here were quite close to that
league I would say that the discussions
are ongoing
we obviously built the arena that hosted
the Stanley Cup finalists our very own
Vegas Golden Knights we were very close
to the NHL we have a robust relationship
with MLB and so that's what I was
suggesting is that the leagues
themselves are trying to figure this all
out and what Adam silver and I have
talked about for the last several months
is we don't have all the answers yet
this is an emerging field but we have
trust in each other and we have the same
goal which is integrity of the game I
could tell you that's the same
conversations we're having with the
other leagues I can't help but think
this relationship a cozy relationship
with the NBA that the Raiders are coming
to town has there been any discussions
with the Commissioner about an NBA team
in Las Vegas well you know we we have a
we've have a relationship with the NBA
before this we're the hosts of the NBA
Summer League which has become you know
a really popular event for the players
fans families etc so that's just getting
bigger and bigger we just finished that
off here I bought last year the San
Antonio stars move them here in the WNBA
there's now the Las Vegas aces and with
our number one draft choice and some
great players were kind of a fun young
team right now
we built t-mobile to be Pro ready for
basketball
and we've hosted many basketball games
we do that we do the pac-12 tournament
at t-mobile right now and we do some
exhibition NBA I would think it would be
highly plausible that an NBA team would
like to relocate to what's becoming one
of the sports capitals of the US but
this was not a precondition of doing
this I have no illusions that it is I
think if a team in the league felt being
in Las Vegas would be a benefit to the
league I think that would happen I
frankly think it will happen this is a
pretty fun place to watch sports and
I've welcomed that we built the arena to
house that can you put down $50 on the
Packers to win the Super Bowl I mean I'm
good for it can you walk downstairs Jim
and do that for me yeah walk right
around the corner but under Nevada laws
they have to know my customer so I know
you so I think that's cool
all right that's good so I got the
Packers at 14 to one odds and win the
Super Bowl
okay I'm with you okay
Jim I appreciate we'll split anything
that we win I would be more than happy
to split it with you okay I'll buy you
dinner out here when we went thank you
Jim thanks for joining us my pleasure
and Cameron for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]